I've known Kristy a few years. And she's been going through a rough time. When her boyfriend dumped her, she wanted to do something. She wasn't over him. And she had all these feelings. And it's hard to just sit there. And she thought about standing outside of his window and serenading him. She's a singer. That's her job. She sings. But she actually had tried serenading a guy once.
我和克里斯蒂认识几年了。她最近过得很艰难。当她的男朋友甩了她之后，她想做点什么。她还没放下他。她心里有各种各样的情绪。干坐着实在太难受了。她想过站在他窗外为他唱小夜曲。她是名歌手，那是她的工作，她靠唱歌为生。但其实她以前试过给一个男人唱小夜曲。
That really didn't work out. I would like to say, as a woman, I believe there is a serenade double standard. Where it's kind of OK for a man to go throw a rock at a window, but when a woman does it, it's sort of like, call the police. There's a singer/songwriter on my lawn.
那次真的很失败。作为女性，我想说，我认为小夜曲存在双重标准。男人往窗户扔石头似乎没问题，但如果是女人这么做，就像是——“快报警，我草坪上有个创作歌手”。
Kind of like you're a crazy person.
就像你是疯子一样。
Yeah.
是的。
And she didn't want to be a crazy person, right? She didn't want to stalk him. She didn't want to bother him. But like I say, she had all these feelings. So she wrote him a letter every day that she did not send. And she started collecting stuff that she knew that he would like. And she kept it. She just kept it in a box underneath her bed. She's also got food for him in her freezer, these pastries that he likes that she saw and couldn't help buying for him.
她不想当个疯子，对吧？她不想跟踪他，也不想打扰他。但正如我所说，她心里有这些情绪。于是，她每天都写信给他，但从不寄出。她开始收集她知道他会喜欢的东西，并把它们存起来。她把这些东西塞在床底下的盒子里。她甚至还在冷冻库里给他准备了食物，那是他喜欢吃的糕点，她看到了就忍不住买给他。
And she knows that he doesn't want to get any of this stuff from her. So what is she collecting this stuff for? She has no idea.
她知道他根本不想收到这些东西。那她收集这些东西是为了什么？她自己也不知道。
Finally, she figured out a way to reach out to him that she thought might be appropriate.
最后，她想出了一个她认为可能比较合适的联系他的方法。
He was a prankster. He loved pranks.
他是个爱恶作剧的人，他很喜欢恶作剧。
Including phone pranks. And so Kristy explained to me that as she would drive around the country from one music gig to the next, she tried to do something that she thought would talk to that part of his personality.
包括电话恶作剧。克里斯蒂向我解释说，当她开车穿梭于全国各地的演出地点时，她尝试做一些她认为能触动他那种个性的事情。
I started writing his number on bathroom walls across the United States.
我开始在全美的厕所墙上写下他的号码。
What?
什么？
Yeah, I started writing on bathroom walls, "Ladies, please help me out. I really want my man back. Please call--" and then I put his number. "And tell him his chalupa really misses him."
是啊，我开始在厕所墙上写：“女士们，请帮帮我。我真的很想挽回我的男人。请致电……”然后我写下他的号码。“告诉他，他的卷饼真的很想他。”
And then I wrote, "Say your city and state, please."
然后我又写道：“请说出你们的城市和州。”
I see. Because you knew that he doesn't want to see you, so you don't want to be calling him. That would be clearly out of bounds.
我明白了。因为你知道他不想见到你，所以你不想直接打电话给他。那显然是越界了。
Right. That's how I cleared myself of that, by having other women call and text him.
没错。这就是我开脱的方法，让别的女人去给他打电话、发短信。
Is it possible, though, if he doesn't want to hear from you, that this is even worse?
不过，如果他不想听你的消息，这样做会不会更糟？
Well, and that's eventually what happened. Two months later, I received a very cold, dry text. "I hope you're doing OK. But please knock it off with the bathroom walls. Desist with this."
嗯，最后发生的就是那样。两个月后，我收到了一条非常冰冷、生硬的短信。“我希望你一切都好。但请别再在厕所墙上乱写了。停止这种行为吧。”
Yeah. So Kristy tried a more constructive route. She started to learn these sad, old country songs, Floyd Tillman and Hank Williams. And she formed a cover band to play them that she calls, The Town Criers-- get it? Town Criers-- in Denton, Texas, where she lives. I asked her to send me one of those songs, and they are really, really sad.
是啊。所以克里斯蒂尝试了一条更具建设性的路线。她开始学习那些悲伤的乡村老歌，比如弗洛伊德·蒂尔曼和汉克·威廉姆斯的歌。她在居住的德克萨斯州丹顿市组建了一支翻唱乐队，取名叫“城镇呐喊者”——懂了吗？城镇呐喊者。我让她寄给我一首，那些歌真的、真的很悲伤。
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐响起]
All of the stuff that Kristy has done since the breakup-- recording this music, playing the prank, buying all that stuff for her boyfriend-- she says she just can't help herself. She still has feelings, and she just has to act.
分手后，克里斯蒂所做的这一切——录制这些音乐、玩恶作剧、为前男友买那些东西——她说她只是无法克制自己。她仍然有感情，她必须采取行动。
I was raised that you can always get what you want out of life, you just have to work hard. And my dad never really explained to me that that didn't apply to love.
从小我受的教育是：你总能得到你想要的生活，只要努力工作就行。但我爸爸从没跟我解释过，这套逻辑不适用于爱情。
Well, today on our radio program, we hear people try all kinds of things, work hard in all kinds of ways for love. Including, I have to say, a few ways that I bet you have never heard of. And they do it because they just can not stop themselves. Like every country song ever written would tell you, they've got no choice. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life, distributed by Public Radio International. It's a special Valentine's Day edition of our show, "What I Did For Love." I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us. Kristy Kruger.
今天在我们的广播节目中，我们听到人们尝试各种方法，为了爱情以各种方式努力。我得说，甚至包括一些你肯定闻所未闻的方法。他们这样做是因为他们真的无法控制自己。就像每一首乡村歌曲所唱的那样，他们别无选择。来自芝加哥WBEZ，这是《美国生活》，由国际公共广播电台发行。这是我们节目的情人节特别版，“我为爱所做的一切”。我是艾拉·格拉斯。请继续收听。克里斯蒂·克鲁格。
Act One, The Best Laid Plans.
第一幕，最好的计划。
When you hear what this first couple did for love, I think one of the things that is most incredible about it is the kind of couple they were when they did it, which is a really great couple.
当你听到这对情侣为爱所做的一切时，我认为最不可思议的事情之一，是他们在做这些事时作为情侣的状态——他们曾是一对非常棒的情侣。
We were always like the most solid of all the relationships of our friends and everything like that.
在我们所有的朋友中，我们的关系一直是最稳固的，诸如此类。
Kurt Braunohler met his girlfriend on the third day of college. And in all of the ways that we think of what makes for a good relationship, I think that they were doing better than you, or me, or most people. They had a lot of fun together. They could talk about anything. They didn't really fight. Happy sex life.
库尔特·布劳诺勒在大学的第三天就遇到了他的女朋友。在我们认为什么是好关系的所有标准上，我认为他们比你、我或者大多数人都做得更好。他们在一起玩得很开心。他们无话不谈。他们几乎不吵架。性生活也很美满。
We really just got along very well together. We traveled well together. We were the place that friends would come when they are having hard times, and they would stay with us. It felt like very adult. Even when I was 23, it felt like, I'm kind of married, even though neither of us had ever, ever discussed getting married.
我们相处得非常融洽。我们一起旅行很合拍。当朋友们遇到困难时，他们会来找我们，住在我们这里。那种感觉非常成熟。即使我在23岁时，也觉得：我好像已经结婚了，尽管我们从来没有讨论过结婚的事。
So what happened?
那么发生了什么？
Well, after we had both turned 30, one day I just kind of was thinking about why we had never talked about getting married. We had never, ever talked about it, seriously or otherwise. And whenever anyone would ask us, we would always just kind of brush it off and say, oh, we'll get married when we have kids. That's what we would always say.
嗯，在我们都过了30岁之后，有一天我突然在想，为什么我们从来没谈过结婚的事。我们从来没有认真地或是随便地讨论过它。每当有人问起我们时，我们总是会搪塞过去，说“哦，等我们要孩子的时候再结婚”。我们总是这么说。
And I remember, we were sitting in the living room and it was October. And I just said, hey, I want to talk. And I said, why do you think we haven't gotten married yet, or even talked about it? And she just kind of like looked at me and thought for a second. And then she said, well, I think that before we get married, we should probably sleep with other people.
我记得那时是十月，我们正坐在客厅里。我直接说：“嘿，我想谈谈。”我问她：“你觉得为什么我们还没结婚，甚至没谈过这件事？”她看着我，思考了一会儿。然后她说：“嗯，我觉得在结婚之前，我们或许应该和别人睡过才对。”
And you would imagine that that would come as a huge shock to me, like hit me hard. But for some reason it made sense to me. I was like, OK, very calmly. And I guess the reason--
你可能会以为这会让我大受震惊，重重地击中我。但不知为何，这对我来说很合理。我很冷静地说：“好吧。”我想原因在于——
Wait, wait. How did that make sense?
等等，等等。这怎么会合理呢？
I've thought a lot about this. And I think that there's a few reasons. We both had this kind of arrogant notion of our relationship, that it could survive literally anything. We had known each other our whole adult lives. We were each other's world. So really, I don't think we thought that we could destroy this thing.
我仔细想过这件事。我认为有几个原因。我们对自己关系的看法有点傲慢，觉得它几乎能挺过任何事情。我们度过了彼此的整个成年时光，我们就是彼此的世界。所以，真的，我不认为我们当时觉得我们会毁掉这段关系。
I talked to the girlfriend who did not want to come on the radio. And she said, basically, that she had only had two boyfriends in her life, her high school boyfriend, who was not a good boyfriend at all, and Kurt, who was great. But she met Kurt, she said, when she was 17. She was 30 when this happened. And she said that she felt like maybe she missed out on something in her twenties, experiences that other people had. And she didn't want to regret that.
我和那位不想上广播的女友聊过。她基本上说，她一生中只交过两个男朋友，一个是高中时的男友，那个人一点都不好；另一个就是库尔特，他很棒。但她说，她17岁遇到库尔特时，发生这件事时她已经30岁了。她说她觉得或许自己在二十多岁时错过了一些东西，错过了别人经历过的那些事，她不想对此感到遗憾。
A warning, I should say, before we go any further in this story. We're going to acknowledge the existence of sex between adults. Nothing explicit.
我得提醒一下，在深入故事之前，我们要承认成年人之间存在性行为。没有露骨的描述。
So they sat on the couch, and they talked this through.
于是他们坐在沙发上，把这件事商量清楚了。
The next part of that conversation was the logistics. Do we break up? Do I move out? Do we just do this while we're living in the same house together? And we kind of came up with this idea of borrowing this Amish concept called rumspringa. And rumspringa in the Amish world is when you're 16, you're allowed to be not Amish for two years. And then when you turn 18, you decide whether or not you come back to the fold.
谈话的下一部分是后勤安排。我们要分手吗？我搬出去吗？我们要住在一起时这么做吗？我们想出了一个借用阿米什人概念的主意，叫“阿米什青年出走期”（Rumspringa）。在阿米什人的世界里，当你16岁时，你可以被允许两年不当阿米什人。等到18岁时，你再决定是否回到群体中。
And during those two years, kids get drunk. They sleep around. They try drugs.
在那两年里，孩子们会喝醉。他们会到处乱睡。他们会尝试毒品。
They do lots of meth.
他们会吸很多冰毒。
They do lots of stuff.
他们会做很多事。
So we decided to have a rumspringa from our relationship. And that's the other crazy thing is that we decided that 30 days was enough. Because probably within 30 days, sleeping with other people, we'll get that all out of our system in 30 days.
所以我们决定在我们的关系中也来一次“出走期”。疯狂的是，我们觉得30天就够了。因为可能不出30天，通过和别人上床，我们就能把这些都从系统里清理出去了。
It turns out, it's really difficult to all of a sudden become single at 31 when you've never been single for your entire life. Because all of a sudden, I'm in New York City, and I'm single. And I essentially have the emotional tools of a 17-year-old boy.
事实证明，在31岁时突然变成单身，而你这一生从没单身过，这是非常困难的。因为突然之间，我在纽约，我是单身。而且我基本上只有17岁男孩的情感工具。
Because the last time you had dated, you were 17.
因为你上次约会时才17岁。
The last time I dated I was in a dorm room. Also, it wasn't like I was single in New York City. Because being single in New York City is, I think, the majority of it is being just very lonely and being on your own. Whereas this was very different. I was in a race. I was in a 30-day race to sleep with as many people as I possibly could. Because after 30 days, I was going to go back and then get married.
我上次约会是在宿舍里。而且，这不像是在纽约市做单身汉。因为在纽约做单身汉，我认为大部分时间是感到非常孤独和独自一人。而这次完全不同。我在参加一场比赛。我在一场30天的比赛中，尽可能多地与人上床。因为30天后，我就要回去结婚了。
So there's a time clock ticking.
所以有一个倒计时钟在走。
Every single-- it was almost to the minute where I'd just be like, if I wasn't out somewhere trying to meet someone, I was like, this is wasted time. I am wasting my time right now.
每一个……几乎每一分钟我都在想，如果我没出门去见某人，我就会觉得：这是在浪费时间。我此刻正在浪费我的时间。
And also, because of the fact that we were both-- my girlfriend and I were both very competitive with each other that we didn't speak during that 30 days. But I think in both of our minds, we had a competitive nature of being like, I need to sleep with more people than she does. And I think she felt the same way.
而且，由于我和女朋友当时都非常好胜，在这30天里我们没有说话。但我认为在我们内心深处，都有种好胜心，想着：我要比她睡过更多的人。我想她也是这么想的。
That's true. She did feel that way. I asked her.
那是真的。她的确是那么想的。我问过她。
So before they started the rumspringa, they took a last romantic trip together to New Orleans over New Years. And they had a great time. And then on January 3, after they both cried a bit, Kurt moved out for a month.
所以在开始“出走期”之前，他们在新年前夕去新奥尔良进行了最后一次浪漫旅行。他们玩得很开心。1月3日，两人都哭了一会儿后，库尔特搬出去住了一个月。
So suddenly, single at 31, time clock ticking, where do you start?
那么，31岁突然单身，时间钟在滴答作响，你从哪里开始？
Well, Kurt called this woman that he knew just a little bit and had a date on the very first or second night. He can't remember which it was. And at dinner, he told her the entire situation. He laid the whole thing out, that he was seeing somebody, they were taking this break to sleep around. And this was a rule that he made for himself, that he was always going to be honest with any woman that he met during this month. He was going to be honest up front.
嗯，库尔特给一个只认识一点点的女人打了电话，第一晚或第二晚就约了会。他不记得具体是哪晚了。在晚餐时，他告诉了她整个情况。他把整件事都摊开了，说他正在和某人交往，他们正在休息期间以尝试与别人上床。这是他给自己定的规则，他会对这个月里遇到的任何女人保持诚实。他打算开门见山。
And that's the weird thing. That's the thing that I still, kind of when I think back on this time, that I don't understand. Like I don't understand how these women that I met during that time heard this story and were like, OK, let's continue with this date.
这就是最奇怪的地方。即便到现在回想起这段时间，我还是不明白。我不明白这些我当时见到的女人听了这个故事后，为什么会说：“好吧，让我们继续这次约会吧。”
What would they say?
她们会说什么？
I think most of them, the overwhelming response was like, "wow" and "I can't believe you're telling me this."
我认为大多数人，压倒性的反应是像“哇”和“真不敢相信你告诉了我这些”。
Kurt was staying on a futon on a friend's living room floor for the month in this apartment where there was no door between the living room and the bedroom where his friend was sleeping. And he brought this woman back on the first date. And they made out a little bit. And then they set another date.
那个月，库尔特睡在朋友客厅地板的折叠沙发上，那个公寓里客厅和卧室之间没有门，朋友就睡在卧室里。他在第一次约会时就带了这个女人回来。他们亲热了一会儿。然后他们又约了一次。
I think it was probably for the next night or the nine after, something like that.
我想大概是第二天或者之后的那天，差不多那样。
And what happens?
然后发生了什么？
What do you mean? What happens on the date?
你是指什么？约会上发生了什么？
I guess I mean, do you sleep with her? Since the whole point of this story is you're trying to sleep with--
我意思是，你和她上床了吗？因为这个故事的核心就是你试图去睡……
Yes.
是的。
I mean, suddenly I felt very modest about asking. But yeah, no.
我的意思是，我突然觉得问这个很不好意思。但是的，没有错。
Yes, we ended up sleeping together.
是的，我们最后上床了。
Yeah.
是啊。
Yeah. It was amazing. It was yeah, totally turned my head around. It really did feel like having experiences like I would imagine I would have had as a teenager. Where sex was this very powerful thing and it kind of overwhelmed you.
对。感觉太棒了。真的，彻底改变了我的想法。那感觉真的像是我想象中青少年时期会有的体验。那时性是如此强大的东西，它能让你不知所措。
A day or two after that, he picks up a woman at a bar, something he had never done before in his life. And he goes home with her. And from there he's off and running. But remember, he has the emotional tools of a 17-year-old.
那之后一两天，他在酒吧里搭讪了一个女人，这是他生平第一次做这种事。他跟着她回家了。从那以后他一发不可收拾。但别忘了，他只有17岁男孩的情感工具。
I was emotionally getting involved with these women. And that was against one of our rules that we had come up-- my girlfriend and I had had a rule saying, no relationships. We don't get into relationships with people. We're just going to go out and sleep with people to see what it's like.
我在情感上和这些女人纠缠在一起了。这违反了我和女朋友制定的规则——我们当时规定，不许发展恋爱关系。我们不去和人谈恋爱。我们只是出去和人上床，看看那是什么感觉。
Oh, I see. But you didn't actually know how to just go out and sleep with somebody without getting emotionally involved.
哦，我明白了。但你实际上根本不知道该如何在不投入感情的情况下直接出去和人上床。
Not at all. I mean, the first date I went on, I immediately was, like, head over heels for her. And I knew her for six hours.
根本不知道。我的意思是，我去约的第一次会，我立刻就为她神魂颠倒了。而我才认识她六个小时。
And I didn't know how to date. I didn't know how to date casually. So what I really was doing was just acting like a person who had been in a 13 year relationship with these women that I had just met.
而且我不知道怎么约会。我不知道怎么随便约会。所以我实际上做的，只是像个和这些刚认识的女人已经谈了13年恋爱的人一样行事。
Like, how does that mean? What do you mean?
就像，那是什么意思？你指的是什么？
Immediately holding hands. I remember that I would-- my impulse would be to say, "I love you" during sex. That would be my impulse, because that's the only way I was used to having sex.
直接牵手。我记得我……我的冲动是想在做爱时说“我爱你”。那是我的冲动，因为那是我就习惯的做爱方式。
And I remember the first time that I did end up having sex, I started to say I love you, and then just kind of swallowed it and made it seem like I was coughing. And that didn't happen just once.
我记得第一次最后还是上床时，我开始说“我爱你”，然后又硬生生吞了回去，假装我在咳嗽。这不只是发生过一次。
Kurt says it was just a month of incredibly intense feelings. He'd feel this crazy elation or he would find himself walking down the street weeping.
库尔特说那是一个充满强烈情感的月。他会感到那种疯狂的狂喜，或者发现自己走在街上泪流满面。
The girlfriend told me that she, meanwhile, is having escapades of her own. She'd be out all night, drinking and dancing, going to exclusive clubs with Mexican high rollers, doing crazy things with European tourists. It was just what she wanted, actually.
女朋友告诉我，与此同时，她自己也有各种艳遇。她整晚都在外面喝酒跳舞，和墨西哥的大亨去顶级夜总会，和欧洲游客做疯狂的事。这正是她想要的，实际上。
And both of them told me that the weirdest thing about that time was that the person that they wanted to talk to most about what was going on and share it with was each other. But of course, they weren't speaking.
他们俩都告诉我，那段时间最奇怪的事情是，他们最想分享这种经历、最想交谈的对象其实是彼此。但当然，他们当时并没有说话。
Kurt says that one of the most amazing thing to him that was kind of a revelation during that time was something-- I've never actually heard anybody talk about it aloud, but I totally related to this-- was how quickly he would find himself in the home of a complete stranger.
库尔特说，那段时间对他来说最神奇、可以说是一种启示的事情是——我从来没听过有人大声谈论这个，但我完全感同身受——那就是他会如此迅速地发现自己身处一个完全陌生人的家中。
Yeah, I had never gotten to see other people's apartments so much. That's what I kind of was fascinated by, getting to see all these different people's apartments and seeing how everyone lives. And I loved that. I loved that part of it so much.
是啊，我从来没有机会看到这么多别人的公寓。那是让我有点着迷的地方，能看到这么多不同人的公寓，看到每个人是怎么生活的。我很喜欢那样。我非常喜欢那一点。
I was like, look at this. Like I'm seeing, this is all your stuff. This is the stuff you keep on your bedside table.
我就像在看：“瞧这个。我看到了，这些都是你的东西。这是你放在床头柜上的东西。”
And also, having like really weird experiences I'd never had before. Of like women picking me up, I had never experienced that before.
而且，体验到了很多我以前从未有过的怪事。比如女人主动搭讪我，我以前从没经历过那种事。
I was so confused, because it was a bartender. She was a bartender. So she just kept giving me drinks, free drinks. And I was like, why is she giving me all these free drinks? But it is fascinating to see, if you stay at the bar until 4:00 in the morning, then all a sudden-- I had never been aware of it before. But then, all of a sudden, looking around me, like, oh, all these people are pairing off. Look at how this happens.
我当时非常困惑，因为那是位酒保。她是个酒保，所以她一直给我免费的饮料。我就想，她为什么要给我这么多免费的饮料？但观察这些确实很迷人，如果你在酒吧待到凌晨4点，那么突然之间……我以前从没意识到过。但突然间，环顾四周，比如，“哦，这些人都在成对离开。”看这事儿是怎么发生的。
I'd been at bars until 4:00 in the morning, but I was always-- it's all of a sudden uncovering this whole level of single life in New York City that I just had not been aware of before.
我在酒吧待到过凌晨4点，但我总是……突然之间，这揭开了纽约单身生活的一个我以前完全没意识到的层面。
Anyone in New York City I feel like can have sex any night of the week if they just follow two rules, which is stay at the bar until 4:00 in the morning and dramatically lower your standards.
我觉得在纽约市，任何人在任何一周的晚上都能搞到性，只要他们遵守两条规则：留在酒吧直到凌晨4点，并大幅降低你的标准。
So after a month, Kurt and his girlfriend get together and talk. And they agreed that a month was not enough for this. They both said, it was just obvious the experiment hadn't run its course. They both wanted more time. So they decide on a second month, which then becomes a third month.
所以一个月后，库尔特和他的女友聚在一起谈了谈。他们一致认为一个月的时间根本不够。他们都说，实验还没达到预期的效果，这很明显。他们俩都想要更多的时间。所以他们决定延长到第二个月，然后变成了第三个月。
And for Kurt, as time went on, it got harder and harder to stick with the rule that they had made of not getting into any relationships. He was just muddling about how to figure out how to do that. In his head, he would think, when is something actually a relationship?
对库尔特来说，随着时间流逝，坚持他们制定的“不发展恋爱关系”的规则变得越来越难。他一直在纠结该怎么做。在他的脑子里，他会想：到底什么时候才算是一段恋爱关系？
And I think in my head I was like, three dates. Three dates makes a relationship. That's what I defined. And so then I would try to not see people more than three times. That was increasingly difficult.
我想在我的脑子里是这样定的：约会三次。约会三次就是恋爱关系。这就是我的定义。所以我会试着不去和人见面超过三次。那越来越困难了。
It was difficult because he was giving women two opposite messages at the same time. He would tell them that he just taking a month's break from his real relationship and this isn't serious. But then he didn't hold back any of his feelings.
这之所以困难，是因为他同时向女人们传达了两个相反的信息。他会告诉她们他只是从真实的恋爱关系中休了一个月的假，这不是认真的。但随后，他却毫无保留地投入了全部情感。
What I felt like kept happening was that I would act like I wanted to be their boyfriend. And then, after three dates, would just abruptly end it, with no explanation whatsoever. And definitely, people would yell at me and call me names. And I feel-- to this day I feel-- I feel horrible about that. Because I was just, I was acting like a crazy person. I was acting like a person with absolutely no boundaries.
我感觉一直发生的事是，我会表现得像我想成为她们的男朋友一样。然后，约会三次后，我会突然结束这段关系，没有任何解释。肯定有人会对我大吼大叫，骂我。我至今——至今都觉得——我觉得对此感到很糟糕。因为我当时只是，我表现得像个疯子。我表现得像一个完全没有界限的人。
Still, it was hard to stop himself while it was going on. And when we talked about it, Kurt's best explanation for that was--
尽管如此，当事情进行时，他很难停下来。当我们谈到这个问题时，库尔特最好的解释是——
When I was a kid, I had a dog. And one day, the cat knocked a five-pound bag of sugar off onto the floor. And my dog was about nine pounds. He was a toy poodle. And he ate all five pounds of sugar in one day. And then he was sick for three days afterwards. But I always think about that day for him, how amazing that day must have been, where like eating all of that sugar and eating it. And then going away from it for a little while, and being like, I can't stop, when is this going to happen again? And then he just started vomiting and vomited for three straight days.
小时候我养过一只狗。有一天，猫把一袋五磅的糖撞到了地板上。我的狗大约九磅重，是一只玩具贵宾犬。他一天之内吃完了那五磅糖。之后他病了三天。但我总是想起对他来说那一天，那一天该有多奇妙，吃掉所有那些糖。然后离开一段时间，想着“我停不下来，这种情况什么时候还会发生？”然后他就开始呕吐，吐了整整三天。
And that's how I felt. I knew this was bad. But I was like, when is this ever going to happen again?
那种感觉就是这样。我知道这很糟糕，但我想：“这种事什么时候才会再发生？”
I asked Kurt's girlfriend if all this happened to her during the rumspringa too. If it was hard just to have sex without emotion entering into it at all. And she said, absolutely not. Quote, "You mean dudes that I meet at bars or parties or whatever, those people?" She said, "I didn't tell anyone anything about my background or the situation."
我问库尔特的女友，这种事在“出走期”期间是否也发生在她身上。是否很难在不投入任何感情的情况下单纯进行性行为。她说，绝对不会。她说，“你是说我在酒吧或派对上遇到的那些男人吗？”她说，“我没告诉任何人我的背景或情况。”
And I asked her, wait. So you wouldn't explain, I'm on a break from a relationship. She said, no, because it sounds crazy. I told her that Kurt would reveal all of that, which she knew. And she said, yeah, yeah, Kurt's way too open. But, quote, "That openness probably just made him more appealing to the ladies."
我问她：“等等，那你不会解释说我正在恋爱空窗期吗？”她说，不会，因为这听起来很疯狂。我告诉她库尔特会和盘托出，她是知道的。她说，是啊，是啊，库尔特太坦诚了。但是，引用她的话，“那种坦诚可能反而让他对女士们更有吸引力。”
By the end of three months, Kurt started to fall for this woman that he met in Australia. And this time, really actually fall for her in a real way. And this made him, of course, feel differently about his relationship with his girlfriend.
三个月结束时，库尔特开始爱上了他在澳大利亚遇到的那个女人。这一次，是真的真心地爱上了她。这当然让他对与现女友的关系产生了不同的看法。
So he flew back to the States, stayed at their old apartment. And because this is the most comfortable relationship that has ever existed between two people, of course they dealt with it all right away, very straightforward.
于是他飞回美国，住在他们原来的公寓里。因为这是两个人之间存在过的最舒服的关系，所以他们当然立刻、非常直截了当地处理了这一切。
And we woke up in the morning, and we went and got brunch. And we brought it to the park, the way we had always used to do on Saturdays. And we just sat in the park, and talked, and we broke up.
我们早上醒来，出去吃早午餐。我们像以前每个星期六习惯做的那样，把它带到公园里。我们只是坐在公园里，谈了谈，然后分手了。
And that's the thing. I can't point to something that was bad about our relationship. Except for knowing that I feel like it had run its course.
就是这样。我找不出我们关系中有什么不好的地方。除了感觉到它已经走到了尽头。
We organically got to the point where we both thought this was a good idea.
我们自然而然地达到了我们都觉得这是个好主意的地步。
This, the rumspringa?
就是这个，“出走期”？
It's almost like the relationship had an expiration date, but we didn't know about it. And then, all of a sudden, we came up with this really complicated, crazy plan to put the test on it at the right place where it would break. And it broke.
这几乎就像是这段关系有一个截止日期，但我们不知道。然后突然之间，我们想出了这个非常复杂、疯狂的计划，在它该结束的地方对它进行测试。它破碎了。
His old girlfriend said something similar. She said she had probably wanted out of the relationship before the rumspringa, but she was just too scared to admit it to herself. The rumspringa gave them a way to break up.
他的前女友也说了类似的话。她说她可能在“出走期”之前就想离开这段关系，但她太害怕，不敢对自己承认。“出走期”给了他们一个分手的方法。
They still are very, very close. They talk a few times a week.
他们现在仍然非常、非常亲密。他们每周聊几次。
Kurt says he would not want to do a rumspringa again. But he came out of this experience believing that it is important to force things to a decision with someone. And that it's healthy for any relationship to be evaluated now and then.
库尔特说他不想再来一次“出走期”了。但他经历了这段体验，相信强迫自己和某人做出决定是很重要的。而且每隔一段时间评估一下任何关系都是健康的。
I do have a theory now. I do have a theory about if I do get married in the future. What I think I would want to do is have an agreement that at the end of seven years, we have to get remarried in order for the marriage to continue. But at the end of seven years, it ends. And we can agree to get remarried or not get remarried.
我现在确实有一个理论。如果我将来结婚，我有一个理论。我想做的是达成一个协议：七年后，我们要重新结婚，婚姻才能继续。但七年后它就结束了。我们可以同意重新结婚，或者不再结婚。
Why?
为什么？
Because I think you get to choose and I think it would make the relationship stronger.
因为我觉得这样你拥有选择权，我认为这会使关系更牢固。
I don't know what I think of that. Because I think, actually, one of the things that's a comfort in marriage is that there isn't a door at seven years. And so if something is messed up in the short-term, there's a comfort of knowing, well, we made this commitment. And so we're just going to work this out. And even if tonight we're not getting along or there's something between us that doesn't feel right, you have the comfort of knowing, we've got time. We're going to figure this out. And that makes it so much easier. Because you do go through times when you hate each other's guts. You know what I mean?
我不知道怎么看这点。因为我认为，实际上，婚姻中令人欣慰的事情之一是七年后没有那一扇门。所以如果短期内出了问题，你会感到安慰，心想：“好吧，我们做出了这个承诺。”所以我们只要解决它就好。即使今晚我们相处得不好，或者我们之间有某种感觉不对劲，你也会感到安慰，心想：“我们还有时间。我们会解决这个问题的。”这让一切变得容易得多。因为你确实会经历彼此厌恶的时候。你明白我的意思吗？
Of course you do. Yeah.
当然明白。是的。
And the no escape clause, weirdly, is a bigger comfort to being married than I ever would have thought before I got married.
奇怪的是，这个“没有逃脱条款”的规定，比我在结婚前想象的更能给婚姻带来安慰。
Really?
真的吗？
Yeah.
是的。
I had never thought of it that way. I like thinking about it that way, you just see so many examples of where people don't think that way.
我从来没那样想过。我喜欢这样思考它，你看到了太多人们不这样思考的例子。
Both Kurt and his girlfriend feel like the rumspringa got them where they needed to go as a couple. Even if that place was different than they intended when they began the whole thing. Sometimes what you need to do next as a couple, you can't even tell what it should be. The best you can do is hold your breath, make a guess, and jump.
库尔特和他的女友都觉得“出走期”让他们达到了作为情侣该去的地方。即使那个地方和他们开始整件事时打算的不同。有时作为情侣下一步需要做什么，你甚至分辨不出应该是什么。你能做的最好的就是屏住呼吸，猜一下，然后跳下去。
[MUSIC - "30 DAYS," RUN-DMC]
[音乐 - “30 DAYS”，RUN-DMC]
Coming up, love stories between a kid and someone who is not a kid, and a duck and someone who is not a duck. And Jeanne Darst and someone who is not Jeanne Darst. That is in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
接下来，关于一个孩子和不是孩子的人，以及一只鸭子和不是鸭子的人之间的爱情故事。还有珍妮·达斯特和不是珍妮·达斯特的人。稍后为您播出，来自芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台，我们的节目继续进行。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today on our program, for Valentine's Day, What I Did For Love. Stories about people who believe in love and do all kinds of things for love. We have arrived at Act Two of our program. Act Two, 21 Chump Street.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天在我们的节目中，为了情人节，谈谈“我为爱所做的一切”。关于那些相信爱情并为爱做各种事情的人的故事。我们现在来到节目的第二幕。第二幕，“21号傻瓜街”。
Last year, at three high schools in Palm Beach County, Florida, a bunch of young police officers were sent undercover to pose as students. These were recent graduates of the police cadet program. And they blended right in. They went to classes. They ate in the cafeteria. The hung out on the basketball court during recess. They had fake Facebook accounts, of course. They even took the state's standardized test, the FCAT. Police officers were there undercover because parents and principals had complained about drugs being sold at the schools. Only the principals at the schools knew of their presence. No teachers knew it, no parents knew it.
去年，在佛罗里达州棕榈滩县的三所高中，一群年轻的警官被派往卧底，装作学生。这些人是警校应届毕业生。他们融入得非常好。他们去上课，在食堂吃饭，休息时间在篮球场闲逛。当然，他们有假的Facebook账号。他们甚至参加了州的标准测试，FCAT。警察在那里卧底，是因为家长和校长投诉学校里有人卖毒品。只有学校的校长知道他们的存在。没有老师知道，没有家长知道。
Now, maybe it is hard to imagine a love story coming out of this situation, but one did. A love story where somebody went out of his way and took action at a key moment for love. Robbie Brown tells what happened.
现在，也许很难想象在这种情况下会产生一个爱情故事，但确实发生了一个。一个有人为了爱，在关键时刻挺身而出、采取行动的爱情故事。罗比·布朗讲述了发生的事情。
The plan was called Operation D Minus. And one of the schools included in the plan was Park Vista Community High School, where a kid named Justin Laboy, an 18-year-old honor roll student, was in the last semester of his senior year.
这个计划被称为“D减行动”。该计划包括的学校之一是公园景观社区高中，一名叫贾斯汀·拉博伊的学生，一名18岁的荣誉生，正在他高中的最后一个学期。
And Justin could hardly believe his luck when a very pretty new girl-- everyone had noticed her-- showed up in not just one, but two of his classes.
当一个非常漂亮的新女孩——大家都注意到了她——不仅出现在他的一门课上，还出现在了两门课上时，贾斯汀简直不敢相信自己的运气。
The name that she used was Naomi. I think it was Naomi Rodriguez. And she sat in front of me, but then I sat next to her. So I started talking to her. Oh, hey, my name is Justin, you know. Oh, I'm Naomi. I'm from New York, this and that. Oh, really? Me too. And I had a hat that said New York on it too, because I was trying to show her that I wasn't lying or faking it.
她用的名字是娜奥米。我想是娜奥米·罗德里格斯。她坐在我前面，但后来我坐在了她旁边。所以我开始跟她搭话：“哦，嘿，我叫贾斯汀。”“哦，我是娜奥米。我来自纽约，诸如此类。”“哦，真的吗？我也是。”而且我戴的帽子上写着纽约，因为我想向她证明我没有撒谎或伪装。
She said she was from Queens. I'm from the Bronx. And she was Puerto Rican and Dominican. And that's what caught me even more. I was like, oh, man. OK. And I was Puerto Rican. And I was talking to her a little Spanish. She talked to me in a little Spanish.
她说她来自皇后区。我来自布朗克斯。她是波多黎各人和多米尼加人。这就是最吸引我的地方。我心想：“哦，天哪。好吧。”而且我也是波多黎各人。我跟她说了点西班牙语，她也用西班牙语跟我交谈。
And then I just got really close to her. I got attached real quick. I was like, wow, look at this.
然后我就和她变得很亲近。我很快就迷上了她。我想：“哇，看看这个。”
What did she look like?
她长什么样？
She was about 5' 4", black straight hair, light-skinned. She was mature body-wise, so that caught a lot of people's attention. But the things that she did that I thought made her a real student was that she would sleep in class. She wouldn't do her homework. I would have to wake her up all the time, be like, hey, listen, wake up. You're going to get in trouble. Hey, oh, you didn't do your homework? OK, I'll let you copy my homework.
她大约5英尺4英寸，黑色直发，皮肤白皙。她的身材发育得很成熟，这吸引了很多人的注意。但她做的一些事情让我觉得她是真正的学生，那就是她会在课上睡觉。她不做作业。我总是不得不叫醒她，说：“嘿，听着，醒醒。你会惹麻烦的。嘿，哦，你没做作业？好吧，我让你抄我的作业。”
Because, I mean, I take my classes seriously. But with her, it was different. I was just like, oh, man, you know? Wow, you know, she's cute. I could talk to her. I'd get in trouble once in a while. It would be like, Justin, stop talking. OK.
因为，我的意思是，我对课程很认真。但对她，情况不同。我就想：“哦，伙计，你知道吗？哇，你知道，她很可爱。我可以跟她聊天。”我会偶尔惹点麻烦。就像：“贾斯汀，别说话。”“好的。”
Justin's a good-looking guy, popular and well-liked. He'd had girlfriends before but nothing that lasted. Nothing that seemed worth holding on to. But Naomi seemed different.
贾斯汀是个长相帅气、受欢迎且人缘很好的小伙子。他以前有过女朋友，但都没有维持太久。没有什么是值得坚持的。但娜奥米似乎与众不同。
She was a good listener. She didn't seem to gossip or play games. She seemed very adult.
她是一个很好的倾听者。她似乎不爱说长道短，也不爱耍花招。她看起来非常成熟。
It's the maturity level that I really cared for. I told her a lot of my feelings. I told her how I felt for her. I mean, I'm not the type of person to open up to you unless we have a really good relationship. And I was just opened up so much. I told her about my whole life story, about my parents. I told her problems I had.
我真正看重的是她的成熟度。我告诉了她很多我的感受。我告诉了她我对她的感觉。我的意思是，除非我们有非常好的关系，否则我不是那种会向人敞开心扉的人。但我敞开得太多了。我告诉了她我整个人生的故事，关于我的父母。我告诉了她我遇到的问题。
What was it about her that made you trust her? That made you feel like you could open up to her?
她身上有什么特质让你信任她？让你觉得你可以向她敞开心扉？
She had told me that she came up here with her mother. That they was having problems in New York, so they came over here to Florida to settle down, to have a better life. And little stuff like that, telling people, I believed that, oh, wow. OK, since you're telling me stuff like this, then I can tell you about my life.
她告诉我她和妈妈搬到这里。说她们在纽约遇到了问题，所以搬到了佛罗里达这里来安定下来，过上更好的生活。像这样的小事，告诉人们，我相信，噢，哇。好的，既然你告诉我这些事，那我也能告诉你关于我生活的事情。
Yeah, I'm having hard troubles with this person right here. Or I'm having trouble with my parents. Little stuff like that makes people bond together.
是啊，我在这个人身上遇到了困难。或者我和父母之间遇到了问题。像这样的小事让人们结为一体。
Justin believed he was seeing the signs that Naomi was starting to like him. Like him like him.
贾斯汀相信他看到了娜奥米开始喜欢他的迹象。那种“喜欢”他的喜欢。
They walked together in the halls. They would text during class. He says she even let him kiss her on the cheek. And he serenaded her in front of their entire class.
他们在走廊里一起走。他们会在课堂上发短信。他说她甚至让他亲吻她的脸颊。他在全班同学面前为她唱了小夜曲。
I'd be like, oh, I'm going to sing you a song. She'd be like, oh, OK. And then I'd just start singing. And then I'll get all blushed up. And be like, oh, man, what am I doing? OK, let me continue. I'll start rapping to her, and then I started singing. And I mean, I even danced too. So I danced for her and I--
我会说：“哦，我要为你唱首歌。”她说：“哦，好的。”然后我就开始唱。接着我脸红了。我想：“哦，天哪，我在做什么？好吧，让我继续。”我开始对着她唱说唱，然后又开始唱歌。我的意思是，我甚至还跳舞了。所以我为她跳舞，然后我——
You really liked this girl.
你真的很喜欢这个女孩。
Man, it tore me apart. I was like, oh my god.
伙计，那让我心碎。我当时想：“哦，天哪。”
So you felt like all the signs were good?
所以你觉得所有的迹象都是好的？
Oh, of course. I felt all the signs were good, because I never got a non-sign. So therefore, I was just like, OK, everything's good. I know I'm taking it slow. I know I'm taking it good. Usually, it doesn't take me that long to get a girlfriend when I start talking to them. So when it took me-- I found it kind of odd. I was like, wow, I'm such a great dude. And we're hanging out. What's the next step? I don't care about sex and everything. I just want to know if you're going to be mine.
哦，当然。我觉得所有迹象都是好的，因为我从没收到过非肯定的信号。所以因此，我就想：“好的，一切都很好。”我知道我进展缓慢。我知道我做得很棒。通常，我开始搭讪一个女孩时，不需要花那么久就能交到女朋友。所以当我花这么久……我发现这有点奇怪。我就想：“哇，我是个这么好的家伙。我们在一起玩。下一步是什么？我不在乎性什么的。我只想知道你是否会成为我的人。”
So she was playing kind of hard to get?
所以她在玩欲擒故纵？
Yes. I mean, me, I love that. So it attracted me even more. I love girls that guys can't have. So I'm like, this is awesome.
是的。我的意思是，我，我喜欢那样。所以它吸引了我更多。我喜欢男人得不到的女孩。所以我心想：这太棒了。
And in hindsight, she was probably playing hard to get for a different reason.
事后看来，她可能出于不同的原因在玩欲擒故纵。
Yes, for a different reason.
是的，出于不同的原因。
All of this built up, inevitably, to Justin asking Naomi to prom. She's a senior, I'm a senior. Our last year, I don't know where we're going to be after this. So let me just step up, and be a man, and do what I got to do.
所有这些最终不可避免地导致贾斯汀邀请娜奥米去参加舞会。“她是高年级学生，我是高年级学生。我们最后一年了，我不知道之后我们会去哪儿。所以让我挺身而出，做个男人，做我该做的事。”
So I went up to her in class. And I was like, listen, I know you don't know anybody in this school that much. And I don't want to go to anybody in this school. And I feel really attracted to you. Would you like to come with me to prom? Oh, that sounds nice. OK. Excuse me, let me think about it.
所以我上课时走到她面前。我说：“听着，我知道你在这个学校不太认识人。我也不想找这个学校里的任何人。我真的被你吸引了。你想和我一起去参加舞会吗？”“哦，听起来不错。好的。不好意思，让我考虑一下。”
I was blushing red. I was like, oh my god, what if she says no? What if she says yes? And after she gave me the OK, yeah, around the more of a yes side, I was OK. I was good. Good.
我当时脸红得像块红布。我心想：“哦，天哪，如果她说不怎么办？如果她说好怎么办？”在她给了我肯定之后，那种偏向“好”一边的回答，我就没事了。我很好。很好。
You know, prom was coming up. And I guess he needed a date.
你知道，舞会快到了。我想他需要一个舞伴。
I interviewed the undercover officer who played Naomi. She's a 25-year-old new recruit with the Palm Beach School's police force. She wouldn't give me her real name, and only agreed to a phone interview if her supervising sergeant could listen in. She wouldn't talk to me about any specific cases, or kids at the school, including Justin. But she did confirm that she was asked to prom. She doesn't remember it quite the way Justin does though. Mainly, she says she didn't say yes.
我采访了那位扮演娜奥米的卧底警官。她是一名25岁的棕榈滩学校警察部队的新兵。她没有告诉我她的真实姓名，并且只有在她的监管中士旁听的情况下才同意电话采访。她没有和我谈论任何具体案件，或者学校里的孩子，包括贾斯汀。但她确实确认她被邀请去舞会了。不过，她记得的情况和贾斯汀的不太一样。主要是，她说她并没有答应。
I told him I wasn't going just because, since this is not where I spent the last three years of high school, I didn't really want to go to the prom. And I had to pay for the ticket and everything else. I was like, no, it's too much money for me. And he bought it.
我告诉他我不去，只是因为，既然这不是我过去三年高中生活的地方，我真的不想去参加那个舞会。而且我不得不付票钱和所有其他东西。我就说：“不，这对我也太贵了。”然后他买了下来。
Justin and Naomi didn't end up going to prom, of course. Partly because of what happened next.
当然，贾斯汀和娜奥米最后没去成舞会。部分原因是接下来发生的事情。
One day at the beginning of April, after Naomi had been at school for about three months, she and Justin had a conversation about drugs.
四月初的一天，娜奥米在学校待了大约三个月后，她和贾斯汀聊起了毒品。
She asked me if I smoked. And I told her, no, I do not smoke. But if you need anything, I'll be more than happy to help you out. So like I said, I'm not a drug dealer. It's hard for me to get drugs at all. So it's not like she told me this day, and then I got it for her the very next day. It took me a while, you know?
她问我是否抽烟。我告诉她，不，我不抽烟。但如果你需要什么，我很乐意帮你。所以就像我说的，我不是毒贩。我根本很难搞到毒品。所以并不是她当天跟我说了，我第二天就为她搞到了。花了我一段时间，你知道吗？
She would text me, and I would text her. She'd be like, do you have it yet? No, I don't have it at the moment right now. And she would be at school, hey, do you have that yet? No, I don't have it right now. I'm sorry. I'm sorry, I'm sorry. I'm really trying. My heart is to get it, and I can't get it. Because I liked the girl.
她会给我发短信，我也会给她发短信。她会说：“你搞到了吗？”“没有，我现在还没搞到。”她会在学校里说：“嘿，你搞到了吗？”“没有，我现在没有。对不起。对不起，对不起。我真的很努力了。我的心是想搞到它，但我搞不到。”因为我喜欢这个女孩。
What are you thinking as you're trying to get this pot to sell to her?
你在试图搞到这些大麻卖给她的时候在想什么？
I'm thinking, what the heck am I doing? Like I had never done this in the school before. So I'm really scared and skeptical about it, too, at the same point. And I'm like, oh, man. OK. So I'm asking my home boy. And my friend is like, no-- I don't know. Because I don't hang out with guys like that.
我在想：“我到底在做什么？”我以前从没在学校里干过这种事。所以我当时也很害怕和怀疑。我心想：“哦，天哪。好吧。”所以我去问我的哥们。我的朋友说：“不——我不知道。”因为我不和那样的人混在一起。
Maybe Justin didn't know guys like that, and maybe he did. The police say he told Naomi he smoked pot. Justin says he was just trying to seem cool to impress her. But what's certain is he did find somebody who would sell to him, a person his cousin knew, he says.
也许贾斯汀不知道那样的人，也许他知道。警方说他告诉娜奥米他抽大麻。贾斯汀说他只是为了看起来酷好打动她。但确定的是，他确实找到了一个愿意卖给他的人，他说那是他表哥认识的人。
So a couple days after they first talked about it, Justin brought a rolled up baggie of marijuana to school for Naomi.
所以在他们第一次谈到这件事的几天后，贾斯汀带了一小袋卷好的大麻到学校给娜奥米。
And I was petrified. I was like, oh my god. I'm actually going to do this.
我当时吓坏了。我心想：“哦，天哪。我真的要这么做了。”
So we were in class. And I sat right next to her. And she was like, hey, do you have that? And I was like, you know what? Yeah, I do. And I was like, OK, we're going to wait a few. Because I'm not going to be like, oh, hey, give it to her in her hand, slide it. But she was like, OK, put it in my purse. OK. She put her purse on top of  my desk. And then I slid it right in there.
所以我们在上课。我坐在她旁边。她说：“嘿，你有那个东西吗？”我说：“你知道吗？是的，我有。”我说：“好吧，我们要等一会儿。因为我不想表现得……哦，嘿，在手里给她，滑过去。”她说：“好的，把它放进我的钱包里。”好的。她把钱包放在我的课桌上。然后我就把它滑了进去。
She goes, OK, now take the money. I was like, no, I don't need the money. It's OK. Just have it. You can take it.
她说：“好了，现在收下钱。”我说：“不，我不需要钱。没关系。留着吧。你可以拿着。”
She goes, no, please take the money. You make me feel bad. So 10 minutes passed. And then we're still arguing about it. I'm like, please. No, I don't want the money. And she goes, no, just take the money. Take the money. Please, take the money. It will make me feel better. I'm just like, OK, you know what? Just so you could just shut up, I'll take the money. Don't worry. You're making me feel bad, now that I'm taking the money from you.
她说：“不，请收下钱。你让我感觉很糟。”所以十分钟过去了。我们还在为这事争论。我说：“拜托。不，我不想要钱。”她说：“不，就收下钱吧。收下钱。拜托，收下钱。这会让我感觉好点。”我就想：“好吧，你知道吗？为了让你闭嘴，我收下钱。别担心。你让我感觉很糟，现在我从你那里收了钱。”
How much money?
多少钱？
$25.
25美元。
And this was at school?
这还是在学校里？
Yes.
是的。
Justin would later find out it's a felony in Florida to sell marijuana. And the penalty is even harsher for selling it on school property. In other words, Justin had made an irreversibly bad decision. The worst decision of his life, he says. And since he was over 18, he was legally an adult when he made it.
贾斯汀后来才知道在佛罗里达州贩卖大麻是重罪。在校区内贩卖的惩罚甚至更严厉。换句话说，贾斯汀做出了一个不可逆转的错误决定。这是他一生中最糟糕的决定，他说。而且因为他已经超过18岁，他在做这个决定时在法律上已经是成年人了。
Finally, in May, the police did a big sweep. They arrested 31 people at several schools, almost all of them students who had sold small amounts of marijuana. Justin was one of them.
最终在五月，警察进行了一次大规模的搜捕。他们在几所学校逮捕了31人，几乎全都是卖过少量大麻的学生。贾斯汀就是其中之一。
And they said that I had sold to the undercover cop. And I'm weirded out. I'm like, whoa. Who did I ever sell to? And then it just popped into my head that the only person that I ever did give anything to was this female. And I was shocked. My emotions were running. I was just like, oh my god. This is so mean. This is so messed up. How can she do this?
他们说我卖给了那个卧底警察。我很奇怪。我心想：“哇。我卖给过谁？”然后我脑子里突然冒出念头，我给过东西的唯一一个人就是这个女性。我惊呆了。我的情绪很激动。我心想：“哦，天哪。这太卑鄙了。这太糟糕了。她怎么能这么做？”
I mean, if it was a guy doing this, if a guy ever tried to come up to me like this, I would have put my hand in his face straight up, and said, no, get out of my face. Please, get out of my face. I don't associate with that. But it's just a female. It's a different feeling that you get for a female than you would when you have your home boy or a guy come up to you and ask you a question like that. Oh, hey, do you smoke? No, no, I don't. Get out of here. It was a different feeling that when you get from a girl you like. You're not going to turn down the person that you want to be with.
我的意思是，如果是一个男人这么做，如果一个男人这样走近我，我会直接把手甩在他脸上，说：“不，离我远点。拜托，离我远点。我不做这种事。”但这只是个女性。比起你哥们或一个男人走过来问你这种问题，你对女性会产生不同的感觉。比如，“哦，嘿，你抽烟吗？”“不，不，我不抽。滚开。”那和你从你喜欢的女孩那里得到的感觉不同。你不会拒绝你想在一起的人。
When I talked to the officer who plays Naomi, she said she had no regrets about her undercover work. She's a cop. And she sees it the way a cop does.
当我采访扮演娜奥米的警官时，她说她对自己的卧底工作没有遗憾。她是警察。她以警察的方式看待这个问题。
These kids need to wake up. They need to realize they can't be doing this.
这些孩子需要清醒过来。他们需要意识到他们不能做这种事。
And using undercover officers has gotten results. The police in Palm Beach County tried the same tactics again at another group of schools last semester. So far, they've arrested more than 80 people. All have pled guilty to charges ranging from selling cocaine and pills to bringing weapons on school property.
使用卧底警察已经取得了成果。棕榈滩县的警察在上学期在另一组学校尝试了同样的策略。到目前为止，他们已经逮捕了80多人。所有人都认罪了，罪名从贩卖可卡因和药片到在学校携带武器不等。
Justin took a plea deal, three years probation in exchange for pleading guilty to the felony charge. His lawyer told him that if he went to trial, it would be his word against Naomi's. And they disagreed about the drug deal.
贾斯汀达成了认罪协议，以对重罪认罪换取三年缓刑。他的律师告诉他，如果他上法庭，那将是他对娜奥米的一面之词。而且他们对毒品交易有分歧。
He says she kept asking him to sell her marijuana. She says he brought it up first. He says she insisted he take money for it. She says he just took the money without prompting. Either way, the police had Justin's text messages telling Naomi he would get marijuana for her. So Justin's lawyer advised him, just take the plea.
他说她一直求他卖大麻给她。她说是他先提出来的。他说她坚持让他收钱。她说他只是在没有催促的情况下就收了钱。无论如何，警方有贾斯汀发给娜奥米的短信，说他会为她搞到大麻。所以贾斯汀的律师建议他，接受认罪协议吧。
But before the deal came through, he spent more than a week in jail going over and over in his mind what had happened. And still thinking, in spite of himself, about Naomi.
但在协议达成之前，他在监狱里待了一周多，在脑海里反复重演发生的一切。尽管他不想，但他仍然在想娜奥米。
I would have a good time when I would be with her. And I would be with her all the time. And that's why, when all this collapsed and caved in, I felt so-- it just hurt.
我和她在一起时很开心。我几乎一直和她在一起。这就是为什么当这一切崩塌时，我感觉如此……它只是伤人。
Have you had any contact with Naomi--
你和娜奥米有什么联系吗——
No, not--
不，没有——
--since you were arrested?
——自从你被捕以来？
Not at all.
完全没有。
Have you tried to send her any messages?
你有没有试过给她发任何信息？
No. I don't have any contact with her whatsoever. If I would, I would love to have a conversation with her. No disrespect or anything.
没有。我跟她完全没有任何联系。如果可以的话，我很想和她谈谈。没有不敬之类的。
What would you tell her?
你会告诉她什么？
I would tell her, what the heck did she do?
我会告诉她，她到底干了什么？
Justin had planned to go into the Air Force after high school. He said he wanted to make something out of his life. And now, with a felony conviction, the Armed Forces, any part of it, was off the table. Justin is applying to community college.
贾斯汀原计划高中毕业后参军。他说他想在生活中闯出点名堂。而现在，有了重罪记录，武装部队，无论哪一个部门，都与他无缘了。贾斯汀正在申请社区大学。
He says now the whole thing seems kind of unbelievable. He was an honor roll student, a first time offender with no criminal record. And of all the high schools in all the towns in all the world, she walked into his.
他说现在整件事看起来有点不可思议。他曾是一名荣誉生，是一个没有犯罪记录的初犯。而在全世界所有城镇的所有高中里，她偏偏走进了他的那一所。
Robbie Brown works for the the New York Times in Atlanta.
罗比·布朗为亚特兰大的《纽约时报》工作。
Act 3, Cold Stone Dreamery. This next story, like that last one we just heard, is about a guy who yearns for someone, yearns. And this someone is not giving him much back. And this someone may not actually be good for him at all. Except in this story, the guy is a duck. This story is from Ben Loory.
第三幕，冷石梦境。下一个故事，就像我们刚才听到的上一个故事一样，是关于一个渴望某人的家伙，极度渴望。而这个人并没有给他太多回应。而这个人可能根本不适合他。只不过在这个故事里，这个家伙是一只鸭子。这个故事来自本·卢瑞。
A duck fell in love with a rock. It was a large rock, about the size of a duck actually, that was situated off the bank of the river, a little past the old elm.
一只鸭子爱上了一块石头。那是一块大石头，大约有一只鸭子那么大，位于河岸边，就在那棵老榆树过去一点点的地方。
Every day after lunch, the duck would saunter off to admire the rock for a while.
每天午饭后，那只鸭子就会溜过去，欣赏一会儿石头。
"Where are you going?" said the other ducks.
“你要去哪儿？”其他鸭子说。
"Nowhere," said the duck. "Just around."
“没去哪儿，”鸭子说。“就随便转转。”
But the other ducks knew exactly where he was going. And they all laughed at him behind his back.
但其他鸭子非常清楚他要去哪儿。他们都在背后嘲笑他。
"Stupid duck is in love with a rock," they snickered. "Wonder what kind of ducklings they will have."
“那只傻鸭子爱上了一块石头，”他们窃笑道。“真想知道他们会生出什么样的小鸭子。”
But there was one duck, a girl duck, who did not laugh. She had known the strange duck for a long time and had always found him to be a good and decent bird. She felt sorry for him. It was hard luck to fall in love with a rock. She wanted to help, but what could she do?
但有一只鸭子，一只母鸭子，没有笑。她认识这只奇怪的鸭子很长时间了，一直觉得他是一只优秀体面的鸟。她为他感到难过。爱上一块石头真是倒霉透顶。她想帮忙，但她能做什么呢？
She trailed after the duck and watched him woo the rock from behind a tree.
她跟在鸭子后面，从树后看着他向石头献殷勤。
"I love you," the duck was saying. "I love you. I love you. I love you. I love you more than the stars in the sky. I love you more than the fish in the river. I love you more than, more than--" And there he stopped for he could think of nothing else that existed.
“我爱你，”鸭子在说。“我爱你。我爱你。我爱你。我爱你胜过天上的星星。我爱你胜过河里的鱼。我爱你胜过……胜过——”他说到这里停住了，因为他想不出还有什么别的东西存在。
"Life itself?" said the girl duck from behind the tree. She hadn't meant to pipe up. The words just sort of leapt out of her.
“生命本身？”母鸭子从树后说。她没打算插嘴。这些话就那样脱口而出。
The duck spun around to look at her. He was terrified.
鸭子猛地转过身看着她。他吓坏了。
"It's OK," said the girl duck, waddling out from behind the tree. "I know you're in love with the rock. In fact, everyone knows."
“没关系，”母鸭子从树后摇摇摆摆地走出来说。“我知道你爱上了那块石头。事实上，大家都知道。”
"They do?" said the duck.
“他们知道？”鸭子说。
"Yes," said the girl duck. "Yes, they do."
“是的，”母鸭子说。“是的，他们知道。”
The duck sighed and sat down on the ground. If he had had hands, he would have buried his head in them.
鸭子叹了口气，坐在地上。如果他有手，他会把头埋在手里。
"What am I going to do?" he said. "What am I going to do?"
“我该怎么办？”他说。“我该怎么办？”
"Do?" the girl duck said.
“怎么办？”母鸭子说。
"How can it go on like this?" Said the duck. "I love a thing that can not speak, can not move, can not-- I don't even know how it feels about me."
“怎么能就这样继续下去？”鸭子说。“我爱着一个不能说话、不能移动、不能……我甚至不知道它对我的感觉。”
The girl duck looked at the rock. She didn't know what to say.
母鸭子看着那块石头。她不知道该说什么。
"I know," said the duck, "you think I'm crazy. You think it's just a rock. But it isn't just a rock. It's different. It's very different." He looked at the rock.
“我知道，”鸭子说，“你以为我疯了。你以为那只是一块石头。但它不仅仅是一块石头。它是不同的。它非常不同。”他看着那块石头。
"But something has to happen," he said, "and soon. Because my heart will break if this goes on much longer."
“但总得发生点什么，”他说，“而且要快。因为如果再这样下去，我的心会碎的。”
That night, the girl duck had a hard time sleeping. She kept paddling around in circles, thinking about the rock, and the duck, and his heart that might break.
那天晚上，母鸭子辗转难眠。她一直在原地不停地划水，想着那块石头，想着那只鸭子，想着他那颗可能破碎的心。
She thought long and hard. And before morning, she had an idea. She went and woke up the strange duck.
她想了很久。天亮前，她想到了一个主意。她去叫醒了那只奇怪的鸭子。
"Things happen when they must," she said, as if it were an extremely meaningful statement.
“事情总会在必须发生时发生，”她说，仿佛那是一句非常有深意的话。
"So?" said the duck.
“所以呢？”鸭子说。
"So I have a plan," said the girl duck, "and I think that it will work."
“所以我有了一个计划，”母鸭子说，“而且我觉得这会管用。”
"Well, what is it?" said the duck, nearly bursting with excitement.
“嗯，是什么计划？”鸭子兴奋得几乎要炸开了。
"We will need help," said the girl duck. "And it will take some time. And also, we will need a cliff."
“我们需要帮忙，”母鸭子说。“这会花些时间。而且，我们需要一座悬崖。”
Two days later they set out. It took four ducks to carry the rock. They worked in teams and traded off every 15 minutes.
两天后他们出发了。需要四只鸭子才能抬动那块石头。他们分队工作，每15分钟轮换一次。
Everyone joined in, even though they laughed, for ducks are all brothers when it comes right down to it.
每个人都加入了，尽管他们都在笑，因为鸭子归根结底都是兄弟。
"The cliff is over that hill and then quite a ways to the south," said the most elderly duck. "I remember flying over it when I was fledgling. It looked like the edge of the world."
“悬崖在那座山后面，往南走很远，”最老的那只鸭子说。“我还是一只小鸟的时候飞过那里。它看起来像是世界的尽头。”
The ducks trudged on under their rocky weight for hours. For hours, and then for days.
鸭子们带着石头的重量跋涉了数小时。数小时，然后是数天。
At night, they camped under hedges and strange trees, and ate beetles and frogs.
晚上，他们在树篱和陌生的树木下露营，吃着甲虫和青蛙。
"Do you think it will be much farther?" said one of the ducks.
“你觉得还要走很远吗？”其中一只鸭子说。
"Maybe," said the old duck. "My memory is not so good anymore."
“也许吧，”老鸭子说。“我的记忆力没以前好了。”
On the sixth day, the ducks began to tire.
第六天，鸭子们开始疲惫了。
"I don't believe there is a cliff," said one of them.
“我不相信有悬崖，”其中一只说。
"Me neither," said another. "I think the old duck is crazy."
“我也不信，”另一只说。“我觉得那只老鸭子疯了。”
"My back hurts," said a third duck. "I want to go home."
“我的背好疼，”第三只鸭子说。“我想回家。”
"Me too," said a fourth. "In fact, I'm going to."
“我也是，”第四只说。“事实上，我正要回去。”
And then, all the ducks began to turn for home. The rock fell to the forest floor and lay there. The strange duck looked imploringly at the girl duck.
接着，所有的鸭子都开始往回走。石头掉在森林的地面上。那只奇怪的鸭子恳求地看着母鸭子。
"Don't worry," she said. "I won't leave you."
“别担心，”她说。“我不会离开你的。”
They watched all the other ducks flee homeward. And then they hoisted the rock onto their backs and trudged on.
他们看着其他鸭子逃离回家。然后他们把石头抬到背上继续前进。
"What do you think will happen when we throw it off the cliff?" said the duck.
“你觉得我们把它扔下悬崖时会发生什么？”鸭子说。
"I don't know," said the girl duck. "I just know it will be something."
“我不知道，”母鸭子说。“我只知道那会发生点什么。”
Finally, they came to the edge of the cliff. The drop-off was so great they couldn't see the ground. Just great white clouds spread out before them, like an endless, rolling cotton blanket.
终于，他们来到了悬崖边。落差太大了，他们看不见地面。只有巨大的白云铺展在他们面前，像一条无尽的、滚动的棉毯。
"It looks so soft," said the duck.
“它看起来真柔软，”鸭子说。
"Yes, it does," said the girl duck. "Are you ready?"
“是的，确实如此，”母鸭子说。“你准备好了吗？”
The duck looked at the rock.
鸭子看着那块石头。
"This is it, my love," he said, "the moment of truth. And whatever happens, please remember, always remember, I love you."
“就是现在了，我的爱人，”他说，“真相大白的时刻。无论发生什么，请记住，永远记住，我爱你。”
And the two ducks hurled the rock off the cliff together.
两只鸭子一起把石头从悬崖上扔了下去。
At first the rock simply fell "like a rock," one might say. "Like a stone." But then something began to happen.
起初，石头只是“像石头一样”掉下去了，有人可能会说。“像一块石头。”但接着，有些事情开始发生。
It began to slow. It began to grow. It began to change. It narrowed. It elongated. And it also spread sideways.
它开始减速。它开始生长。它开始变化。它变窄了。它变长了。而且它也向两侧延伸。
"It's becoming a bird," the girl duck said.
“它正在变成一只鸟，”母鸭子说。
And it was. It was becoming a beautiful gray bird, really not that unlike a duck. Its wings began to move slowly up and down, up and down. And it dove down, and then coasted up. It looked back over its shoulder at the two ducks on the cliff, and it called out just once, "Good bye."
确实如此。它变成了一只美丽的灰鸟，其实和鸭子没什么两样。它的翅膀开始缓慢地上下移动，上下移动。它俯冲下去，然后又滑翔而上。它回头看了看悬崖上的两只鸭子，只叫了一声：“再见。”
And then it was going, going, getting smaller and smaller, flying off over the blanket across the sky.
然后它就走了，走了，变得越来越小，飞过了天空那层毯子。
When they reached the pond, the other ducks gathered around and clamored to hear what had happened. The duck and the girl duck glanced at each other.
当他们回到池塘时，其他鸭子围了上来，吵着要听听发生了什么。鸭子和母鸭子对视了一眼。
"Nothing," said the girl duck. "It fell."
“没什么，”母鸭子说。“它掉下去了。”
In the days that followed, the duck stayed to himself. The girl duck went and swan around in circles. She thought about that rocky bird flying off into the sky. She saw it over and over in her mind.
在接下来的几天里，鸭子独自呆着。母鸭子游来游去。她想着那只飞向天空的石头鸟。她在脑海里一次又一次地回想它。
And then one day, not too many days later, she looked and saw the duck come swimming up. He was carrying a small salamander in his bill.
然后有一天，没过几天，她看到那只鸭子游了过来。他嘴里叼着一只小蝾螈。
"For me?" the girl duck said.
“给我的？”母鸭子说。
And the duck smiled.
鸭子笑了。
Ben Loory, reading a story from his book, Stories for the Nighttime and Some for the Day.
本·卢瑞，正在朗读他书中的故事，《夜间故事，以及一些白日故事》。
Act Four, Fantastic Mr. Fox.
第四幕，神奇的狐狸先生。
When you're first falling for somebody, there is that period where you don't know if you should trust what is happening just yet, or should you trust them? And this question mark hangs over the whole thing. And part of what you're doing for love is gathering information to erase that question mark.
当你第一次爱上某人时，有一个阶段，你不知道是否应该信任正在发生的事情，或者是否应该信任他们？这个问号悬在整件事上方。你为爱所做的一部分就是收集信息来消除那个问号。
Jeanne Darst met this guy, and thought of him as a fling and not serious dating material. At first, anyway.
珍妮·达斯特遇到了这个家伙，起初把他当作艳遇，而不是严肃的约会对象。反正起初是这样。
Note to sensitive listeners. Once again, we refer to the existence of sex in this story, but give no details about how it works. Anyway, here's Jeanne.
给敏感听众的备注。我们再次提到了性在这个故事中的存在，但没有详细说明它是如何运作的。总之，这就是珍妮。
It was a pretty romantic set up. He was photographing me for a work thing.
那是一个相当浪漫的安排。他在为一个工作项目给我拍照。
My first impression of him was that he was a little silly, like a lot of men in Los Angeles are. Wearing goofy, expensive sneakers like a rich five-year-old and mispronouncing words. But also, super likable.
我对他的第一印象是他有点傻，就像很多洛杉矶男人一样。像个有钱的五岁小孩一样穿着滑稽昂贵的运动鞋，发音不准。但也超级招人喜欢。
As we were talking about the layout for the shoot, he asked me, what do you think of monogamy? Later, when we had been dating a while, I asked him why he asked me what I thought of monogamy. And he said, because I wanted to date someone who wanted to be monogamous.
当我们讨论拍摄方案时，他问我：“你对一夫一妻制怎么看？”后来，当我们约会了一段时间后，我问他为什么问我对一夫一妻制的看法。他说，因为我想和想实行一夫一妻制的人约会。
The second time we met, he asked me to his house for a margarita. When I told him I was sober, he said, that's amazing. I'm sober a lot of the time too. I haven't had a drink for eight days.
我们第二次见面时，他约我去他家喝玛格丽特酒。当我告诉他我戒酒时，他说：“那太棒了。我很多时候也戒酒。我已经八天没喝酒了。”
The ridiculousness of this was somehow exceedingly charming to me. Someone who, in trying to play down their drinking, has no idea that everything they're saying is screaming I'm an alcoholic.
这种荒谬感不知为何对我来说极具魅力。一个试图掩饰自己饮酒习惯的人，根本不知道他所说的每一句话都在尖叫：“我是个酒鬼。”
Normal drinkers don't know how many days it has been since their last drink. In the way that, say, I couldn't tell you when I last had red potatoes.
普通酒友不会记得自己最后一次喝酒是多少天前。就像，我没法告诉你我最后一次吃红薯是什么时候。
I guess I had thought that I would play in his power of now world for a week or two. That Jake and I would have fun, and that would be that. But things were quickly, well, better than that. We had a lot in common. He was divorcing like me, had a kid my kid's age. He understood having dinner at 5:30.
我想我原本以为我会进入他那“当下”的力量世界里待上一两周。我和杰克会玩得很开心，仅此而已。但情况很快……好吧，比那更好。我们有很多共同点。他和我一样在闹离婚，有个和我孩子同龄的孩子。他理解在5:30吃晚饭的意思。
He was sexy, and sexy, and had good ideas about things to do. He'd call and say, let's take the boys to an outdoor movie at the golf course tonight. And when I'd be in the middle of a work thing and realize we were all going to starve, I'd get a text saying he was making sandwiches, and bringing blankets and pillows, and picking us all up.
他很性感，性感，而且对要做的事情很有想法。他会打电话来说：“今晚带孩子们去高尔夫球场看露天电影吧。”而当我忙于工作、意识到我们都要饿坏了时，我会收到短信，说他正在做三明治，带着毯子和枕头，准备接我们所有人。
He called me Fox-- constantly. I forgave this because I thought it was a professional tick. And after my divorce, I wasn't looking for an argument.
他不停地叫我“狐狸”（Fox）。我原谅了这点，因为我认为这是一种职业习惯。而且离婚后，我不想找茬。
I soon realized he called everyone Fox. Hey, Fox. My neighbors, his agent. He probably called his own mother Fox. What's up, Fox, how's the arthritis?
我很快意识到他叫谁都是“狐狸”。嘿，狐狸。我的邻居，他的经纪人。他可能连他亲妈都叫狐狸。“怎么了，狐狸，关节炎怎么样了？”
My friends don't want to be called Fox. They really, really don't want to called Fox. But again, I let it ride because he worked in the fox industry, and had done a lot of drugs, and was pushing 50. Maybe he couldn't remember anyone's name.
我的朋友们可不想被称为狐狸。她们真的很、真的很不想被称为狐狸。但再说一次，我让它顺其自然，因为他在狐狸行业工作，吸了很多毒，快五十岁了。也许他记不住任何人的名字。
Despite his stale vaudeville sleazy photographer routine, he seemed to be a lot more serious about getting serious than I was. After about a month and a half, he told me he was in love with me. I didn't say the same back because, while I was definitely crazy about him, something was off.
尽管他有老掉牙的杂耍般油腻摄影师作派，但他似乎比我更认真地对待认真谈恋爱这件事。大约一个半月后，他告诉我他爱上我了。我没有回应，因为虽然我绝对为他疯狂，但有些地方不对劲。
For instance, I sensed that Jake needed to make a connection to other women as well-- everywhere we went. Like the sales lady at CVS. Who the hell cares about this person? Can we go? Do you really need her to think you're terrific?
例如，我感觉到杰克也需要和别的女人建立联系——无论我们走到哪儿。就像CVS的销售小姐。谁会在乎这个人？我们能走吗？你真的需要她觉得你很棒吗？
A month later, we went to New York for work and Thanksgiving. And he went down to use the building's gym. Ad his journal was right there. Right there.
一个月后，我们去纽约工作并过感恩节。他去楼下的健身房。他的日记就放在那儿。就在那儿。
I'd like to tell you that I had some hesitation about whether to open this thing up and read it. That I thought for even one single second about right and wrong. But I didn't.
我很想告诉你们我当时犹豫过是否要打开这东西读一读。我哪怕一秒钟思考过对错。但我没有。
In his diary, there were some interesting entries. But let's see, the one that jumped out was Friday was Miho, Saturday was Kiku, Sunday was Jeanne. Miho and Kiku are clearly women's names. So again, that was Friday was Miho, Saturday was Kiku, Sunday was Jeanne.
在他的日记里，有一些有趣的条目。来看看吧，跳入眼帘的是：“周五是美穗，周六是纪久，周日是珍妮。”美穗和纪久显然是女人的名字。所以再次强调，那是：“周五是美穗，周六是纪久，周日是珍妮。”
And then he wrote, "What's going on with me?" Three women in three days? What's going on with you? Well, a lot, apparently.
然后他写道：“我这是怎么了？”三天内三个女人？你这是怎么了？好吧，显然发生了很多事。
And then I read that he did not have an attraction to-- page turn-- white women. White women like me.
然后我读到他并不被——翻页——白人女性吸引。像我这样的白人女性。
I knew he had dated some Asian women and his ex-wife was Asian. He had Asian assistants, but I didn't think too much about it. I guess that's why I got Sunday.
我知道他约会过一些亚洲女性，他的前妻也是亚洲人。他有亚洲助手，但我没太在意。我想这就是为什么我得到了周日。
Maybe it was my fault. I probably should have said right at the start of the relationship, I'm not Asian-- before anyone got hurt. Me. Before I got hurt.
也许是我的错。我可能在关系开始时就应该说：“我不是亚洲人。”在有人受伤之前。我。在我受伤之前。
I felt like I had been thrown across the room. Delusion is one thing. Self-delusion is in my bones. But lying? Those aren't my people, liars. There's no style in lying. There's no honor, no panache. And there was no need. I was going way slower than he was, had, in fact, suggested to him that we keep things loose, see other people. But he insisted he did not want to see other people.
我觉得我被狠狠地羞辱了。自欺欺人是一回事。自欺欺人刻在我的骨子里。但撒谎呢？那些不是我的人，撒谎者。撒谎毫无格调。没有荣誉，没有风度。而且完全没必要。我比他进展慢得多，事实上我曾建议他我们保持开放，见见其他人。但他坚持说他不想见其他人。
I then read in the journal, "There are some real red flags with Jeanne."
我随后在日记里读到：“珍妮身上有一些真正的危险信号。”
Red flags, me. I've got red flags. I've been flagged. You're banging two other women on this page alone and you flag me?
危险信号？我？我有危险信号？我被打上标记了。你光在这一页上就和另外两个女人鬼混，然后你标记我？
I decided then and there that I had just been handed my new stage name, Redd Flaggs-- two D's, two G's.
我当即决定，我刚才收到了我的新艺名，雷德·弗拉格斯（Redd Flaggs）——两个D，两个G。
I stopped reading, and grabbed my jacket, and headed out to meet my friends. I texted him what I had done, and said I would get my things later. I got a text back saying, "Don't run, Jeanne. Talk."
我停止阅读，抓起外套，出门去见我的朋友们。我发短信告诉他我做了什么，并说我会晚点去取东西。我收到回信说：“别跑，珍妮。谈谈。”
Don't run? Don't run? I can't put on my Nikes fast enough, Fox. I never talked to him again.
别跑？别跑？我穿上耐克鞋的速度快得不能再快了，狐狸。我再也没跟他说过话。
The following morning, I drove to a house in the country for Thanksgiving with my sister, and her husband, and two kids, and a bunch of old friends.
第二天早上，我开车去乡下的一栋房子和我的姐妹、她的丈夫、两个孩子以及一群老朋友共度感恩节。
I had woken up sick, and by the time the car pulled into the driveway, I had laryngitis and couldn't speak. So for the next two days, in this house in the woods, I couldn't say a word.
我醒来时病了，等车开进车道时，我患上了喉炎，无法说话。所以接下来的两天，在这座林子里的房子里，我一句也说不出来。
I sat by the blazing fire outside, the white girl whose boyfriend didn't like white girls. Yes, he was a jerk. But I was a snoop. I now actually felt bad about what I'd done.
我坐在燃烧的壁炉旁，那个男朋友不喜欢白人女性的白人女孩。是的，他是个混蛋。但我是个窥探者。我对自己做过的事现在真的感到难过了。
That night, everyone else took turns telling me their snooping stories, trying to cheer me up. My favorite was one from my sister, Liz.
那天晚上，其他人轮流告诉我他们的偷窥故事，试图让我振作起来。我最喜欢的是我姐妹莉兹讲的故事。
He started out-- it was one of those relationships where he started out super enthusiastic, like showing up at my office and calling all the time. And giving me presents, and really, really into it.
他刚开始的时候——那是一段关系，他刚开始时超级热情，就像出现在我的办公室并一直打电话。给我礼物，而且非常、非常投入。
This was back when she was about 24 and dating this musician. After four months, it went suddenly, unexpectedly cold.
那是她大约24岁、和一个音乐家约会的时候。四个月后，他突然、出人意料地冷淡了下来。
So I just wanted to find out what happened and why he changed his opinion.
所以我只是想找出发生了什么，为什么他改变了看法。
I was at his apartment. He went into the shower, and he left his diary sitting out, which is something-- he was always writing in his diary. It was just sitting there, sort of burning a hole in the nightstand, as I was sitting on the bed. And I finally couldn't take it anymore. I just figured, I'll just take one little peek. Just to sort of see what he's thinking about. And you get that feeling when you're going out with someone, you don't really know them, and you're just trying to get to know them better.
我在他的公寓里。他进浴室洗澡，把日记放在那儿，那件事……他总是写日记。它就放在那儿，就在床头柜上烧出了一个洞，我就坐在床上。我终于忍无可忍了。我想：“我就看一眼。看看他在想什么。”当你和某人约会，不太了解他们，只想更好地了解他们时，你就会有那种感觉。
So the first page I opened to I see what basically looks like a to-do list. And it's like, buy new guitar picks, get air conditioner fixed, call Grandma on her birthday, or something. And number four was break up with Liz. So it was just like the saddest-- it was the most mundane list of boring things that he eventually had to get around to doing. And I was the fourth on the list?
所以我打开的第一页，看到的看起来基本上是一张待办事项清单。上面写着：“买新吉他拨片，修理空调，在奶奶生日时给她打电话，”之类的。第四条是“和莉兹分手”。所以那简直是最悲伤的……那是他最终必须得做的最琐碎、最无聊的事情清单。而我排在清单的第四位？
And then, I guess looking for more info, I just kind of quickly flipped through to see a couple things. And just, my eye-- your eye is just searching for your own name. And I saw something about like, problems with Liz. And one was like, Liz's boobs are too big. And I was like, what kind of person says that about someone? It wasn't like I was 80 years old, and I had like the world's saggiest ones. I was like, are you crazy?
然后，我想大概是寻找更多信息，我就快速翻了翻想看点什么。然后，我的眼睛……你的眼睛只是在搜索你自己的名字。我看到了一些关于“和莉兹的问题”。其中一个是像“莉兹的胸部太大”。我当时就想：“什么样的人会这样说别人？”又不是说我80岁了，我有世界上最下垂的胸部。我心想：“你疯了吗？”
She's too pretty.
她太漂亮了。
Yeah.
是啊。
After reading his diary, she ran home and called him up and broke up with him, beating him to the punch, basically. Liz isn't all that hung up on snooping being wrong. She just feels like it always bite you in the butt.
读了他的日记后，她跑回家给他打电话并甩了他，基本上抢在他之前下手。莉兹并不觉得偷窥是错的。她只是觉得偷窥总是会反过来咬你一口。
And she's right. Reading Jake's journal did bite me in the butt. Some of what I read was so gross, there were unsavory details that I haven't talked about here. Details that I don't like having in my head.
她说得对。读杰克的日记确实反咬了我一口。我读到的一些东西太恶心了，还有些我不喜欢在这里谈论的卑劣细节。我不喜欢自己脑子里有这些细节。
This is the high price of wanting to know the truth, you know the truth. And I don't want to snoop anymore. But it wasn't the dumbest thing I've ever done. It erased the question mark that hangs over every relationship at the beginning and gave me a clear answer.
这就是想知道真相的高昂代价，你知道了真相。我不想再偷窥了。但这并非我做过最蠢的事。它消除了每段感情刚开始时悬而未决的问号，并给了我一个明确的答案。
It was horrible and devastating, and I'm glad I did it. I mean, without the proper intel, how was I supposed to know Jake was a liar? My sister, Liz, even liked him.
这很可怕、很具毁灭性，但我很高兴我这么做了。我的意思是，没有适当的情报，我怎么能知道杰克是个骗子？我的姐妹莉兹甚至还喜欢他。
He was just always like peppy and funny. And was like, huggy. And I don't know. Calling everyone beautiful, and sexy, and foxy.
他总是看起来充满活力、很有趣。而且像是……很喜欢拥抱。我不知道。叫每个人漂亮、性感、狐狸。
Ugh, Fox.
呃，狐狸。
Fox.
狐狸。
God.
天哪。
It's not so bad, is it?
没那么糟，对吧？
Yes.
是的。
I got hurt. Redd Flaggs got hurt.
我受伤了。雷德·弗拉格斯受伤了。
I don't think I'll ever read anyone's journal again. I never want to know what someone thinks of me in that kind of way ever again. It's too intense. I know I'm not Asian. I know I had reservations about Jake, instincts, which is why I read the journal.
我想我再也不会读任何人的日记了。我再也不想知道别人那种对待我的想法了。这太强烈了。我知道我不是亚洲人。我知道我对杰克有保留意见，有直觉，这就是为什么我读了那本日记。
Jeanne Darst. She's the author of the memoir, Fiction Ruined My Family. She is single.
珍妮·达斯特。她是回忆录《虚构毁了我的家庭》的作者。她目前单身。
[MUSIC - "LOVE'S GONE BAD," CHRIS CLARK]
[音乐 - “LOVE'S GONE BAD”，CHRIS CLARK]
Well, our program was produced today by Jonathan Menjivar and myself, with Alex Blumberg, Ben Calhoun, Sarah Koenig, Miki Meek, Lisa Pollak, Brian Reed, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Seth Lind is our production manager. Emily Condon is our office manager. Production help from Matt Kilty. Scouting help from Elna Baker. Music help from Damien Graef and Rob Geddis.
嗯，我们的节目今天由乔纳森·门吉瓦尔和我本人制作，还有亚历克斯·布隆伯格、本·卡尔霍恩、莎拉·凯尼格、米基·米克、莉萨·波拉克、布莱恩·里德、罗宾·塞米恩、阿丽莎·希普和南希·厄普代克。我们的高级制作人是朱莉·斯奈德。塞斯·林德是我们的制作经理。艾米丽·康登是我们的办公室经理。制作协助来自马特·基尔蒂。考察协助来自埃尔娜·贝克。音乐协助来自达米安·格拉夫和罗布·格迪斯。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
Kurt Braunohler, the guy in Act One, used to tell a version of his rumspringa story on stage-- he's a comedian-- in a show called, "The Amish Guide to [BLEEP]."
第一幕中那个家伙库尔特·布劳诺勒，曾经在舞台上讲述过他“出走期”故事的版本——他是个喜剧演员——在一个叫“阿米什人的[哔]指南”的节目中。
Kristy Kruger who sang the song at the top of the show is on the internet at kristykruger.com. Both Kristy and Kruger are spelled with a K.
在节目开头唱歌的克里斯蒂·克鲁格在互联网上是kristykruger.com。克里斯蒂和克鲁格名字里的字母K拼写是一样的。
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. WBEZ management oversight for our show by our boss, Mr. Torey Malatia.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。WBEZ对我们节目的管理监督来自我们的老板，托里·马拉蒂亚先生。
I keep asking him to come onto the radio program and do his Michael Jackson imitation. He always says--
我一直求他来广播节目里模仿迈克尔·杰克逊。他总是说——
Oh, that sounds nice. OK. Let me think about it.
哦，听起来不错。好的。让我考虑一下。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life .
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。